et bien c'est amusant vous voir réunis
tous les deux un
vous cumulez combien à bout de
90 ans de petites magouilles
politiciennes c'est ça
veut dire que vous êtes vraiment le
tandem du renouveau
non mais blague à part c'est quoi l'idée
générale
vous pensez que parce que vous avez
absolument tout raté chacun de votre
côté il suffit de vous mettre ensemble
pour réussir quelque chose c'est ça
ouais enfin georges ont tenu de la chute
est comme eux dans les limites du
raisonnable
ah pardon excusez moi non non mais c'est
très bien au contraire c'est très bien
fauconnier c'est très bien dans les
vrais débats ça cogne c'est pas parce
que françois et moi dirais qu'il faut
laisser tomber alors allez-y
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire modéré
modéré
prudent précautionneux indécis puissent
ils animent timoré frileux inconsistant
modéré le bien agressif tout d'un coup
que ce qui vous aurais je suis agressif
ça m'arrive je vous prie de l'excuser
tout le monde peut pas être un type
normal qu'ils bouffent du miel et qui
fait joli coeur avec les femmes mariées
je fais rien de spécial vous savez c'est
pas de ma faute si je plais
mes chers compatriotes
l'heure est grave
la france
elle est au bord du gouffre
dans ces circonstances exceptionnelles
j'ai la grande joie de vous annoncer mon
retour
au cinéma
votre retour au cinéma nicolas c'est pas
le concordat pts et black fois soit donc
si votre retour au cinéma dans un film
souffre et ne l'entendent de presse je
vous entends je souffre mais je dis tu
le sais votre retour généralement je
fais ce que je dis
n'est pas mon professeur je suis pas
neutre il va pas me dire qui je suis qui
je ne voudrais pas vivre les 17,1 en
sont si c'est un mensonge une sélection
calomnie kalemie nateur
retour au cinéma
si vous voulez
savez pour être président faut être
calme
[Musique]